the return and live-action debut of cad
bane was by no means the biggest
surprise but a welcome one in the latest
book of boba fett episode as boba fett
is the iconic bounty hunter more of his
fellow ones were no now going to appear
and i look forward to other people like
bosk and even dengor showing up dengo
dengo high voltage what you're here for
though besides my lovely singing voice
is to learn about cad bane the
incredibly powerful being known to take
on jedi and he's someone that's going to
be a fierce opponent for boba's new crew
but who is he and what are his hopes and
dreams well throughout this video that's
what we're going to be going over so
hold on to your butts as we break down
the entire character if you enjoy it
then please smash the thumbs up button
and also don't forget to subscribe for
the quickest straw in the galaxy without
the way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into cad bane okay so the
hunter from duros first appeared in the
clone wars episode hostage crisis and
was instantly a standout with his wild
west cowboy look he was born around 62
bby on the planet giro which is a part
of the galaxy's core worlds prior to the
events of the clone wars he was
extremely notorious and he worked with
django fed owing many debts to him
before his demise during production the
clone wars was originally set to focus
on the war itself but it ended up
branching off into other stories which
introduced new characters whilst fans
loved the expansion of the star wars
lore and those that shot up i'm sure
many would have preferred not to have
met the martes sisters but you can't
love star wars if you don't also hate it
though the jedis and troops took a big
focus eventually a bounty hunter was
needed for certain story plot points and
originally this was the character durge
from the clone wars over time though
things changed and evolved and we ended
up with a cad bane we know today based
on angel eyes from the good the bad and
the ugly during the design stages filoni
used the concept illustration for a
gunslinger originally intended for the
original trilogy and due to this baines
brought an extremely impulsive look with
him now diege wasn't wife from the saga
and he would later appear in the current
canon in doctor aphra's comics who
herself would make a great disney plus
show bane has had a number of amazing
stories including the time he worked
with darth maul in order to track down a
jedi padawan once the clone wars began
though cad bane really came to the
forefront and he rose to be one of the
top bounty hunters after django was
killed on geonosis his expertise and
services were acquired by the top power
players across the galaxy and this
included the likes of the huts count
dooku and also darth sidious his
equipment included a techno service
droid named toto 360 and he always packs
his trademark weapons the ll-30 blaster
pistols he also has the typical tools of
the trade that any bounty hunter would
use such as a flamethrower and also a
rope bain even had special breathing
tubes to counter force choking and
rocket boots that meant he could keep it
with those that had jetpacks he also
used gauntlets that allowed him to
electronically shock anyone which even
the powerful obi-wan kenobi fell fell
off now when going to the skies bane
flew a borax 38 star fighter named
xanadu blood which he gained after a
holocron heist job given to him by darth
sidious post clone wars he flew a ship
named the justifier which we saw in the
bad batch when the character attempted
to capture omega throughout the saga
we've seen cadbane take on many jobs
with his first one in the clone wars
involving a rescue attempt on zero the
hutt he then appeared with another
powerful bounty hunter called aura singh
who herself would join up with a young
boba fett later in the animated series
nakat's introduction was swift and
impactful for his fans and he would be
hired by darth sidious to steal the
aforementioned holocron from the jedi
temple the holocron along with a kyber
crystal would list all four sensitive
children in the galaxy but he would be
pursued by the jedi and would allow
himself to be captured to later give
them the slip kadbane would also allow
himself to be caught to infiltrate a
prison and extract a prisoner who was
working for count dooku with a guy named
hardim that was actually obi-wan kenobi
he went to meet dooku for payment only
to be put into a cube slash escape room
test for the rights to a job to kill
chancellor palpatine yikes here we saw
just how important his trademark wide
brim hat was to him as he killed someone
for simply touching it never rub another
man's rhubarb now this episode was
superb and the entire arc is worth
watching if you haven't seen it before
it starts with episode 15 of season 4
and ends with obi-wan taking down cad
bane so he can't kill palpatine i bet
he's not the obi-wan or regretting doing
that now he would later assist the
separatists with their plans to bomb the
jedi temple sadly due to the clone wars
cancellation there were a lot of
interesting arcs involving him that got
cut the most notable of these being the
story between cadbane and boba fett in
the episodes which were never finished
the pair would team up for a mission on
tatooine and the relationship between
jango and kad would have been explored
in more detail cad would have also
gained the justifier's ship which would
later appear in the bad batch now cad
bane would have taken boba fett truly as
an apprentice and this would later lead
to cad coming to blows with him after he
stopped an insurrection in the shootout
which was somewhat murdered in the book
of boba fett the pair both shot each
other and bane was meant to be the one
that caused the dint in boba's helmet
sadly the character didn't sharpen star
wars rebels except for a piece of
graffiti that was made by sabine wren
aboard the ship ghost it would be a very
very long time before the gunslinger
would return once more and for years
people speculated that he was dead the
unfinished episode actually had boba
shooting bane and in the bad batch he
returned with a plate on his head
showing that he might have survived this
and that it could be considered cannon
now cad was high to take omega back to
camino and it became clear that the
years and jobs didn't take any toll on
him during history introduction the guy
was a total chad
chad bane i'm copyrighting that now he
went toe-to-toe with the bad batch and
actually managed to outsmart them and
take omega now fenix shan was hot on his
tail and we discovered that she'd taken
out his contact the pair fought which
gave colomforce 99 just enough time to
save omega and it was a really gripping
episode whilst it seemed like a curious
cameo at the time we now know what was
being set up see guys we just have to
trust the process of the felony verse as
he's been creating the best star wars
since george lucas himself now this was
the last time before he appeared in the
book of boba fett and with the day
fellaini episode featuring two clone
wars characters i wonder who else will
be added when he helms another entry
surely that would have to be the return
of ezra bridger or it could be thrawn
who's rumored to be in the ahsoka series
now as for his appearance in the book of
boba fett he is set for a direct
collision course with bulba fennek and
mando he appeared in episode six for a
duel straight out of the good the bad
and the ugly in some of the best shots
that we've had in this season it fits in
so well with the western style of the
mandalorian and now the bugger bubba
fett has managed to capture it too in
the scene we watch kov vant without the
armor that allowed him to protect his
town and it was only a matter of time
before someone got the better of him
whether he's dead or not remains to be
seen but i do think that the character
will return as the people in the village
were acting like he was hurt and not
dead beyond this though i'm hoping that
dave filoni and john favreau have
managed to use some of the last episodes
of the clone wars and are setting up for
a fight between cadbane and boba fett i
mean let's be honest the guy's not
really done a lot he was almost even
just a cameo in the last episode and it
would be great to see the dangerous
bounty hunter finally get a fight this
has been lacking this season and seeing
him take on cad bane would at least give
the guys something to do now would be
nice if some of the cancelled story from
the clone wars could be added
retroactively and in many ways this
would heighten the tension between both
barbara and cad it would explain why cat
took this job specifically as he would
have a score to settle with fennec and
also boba whether that happens we'll
just have to wait and see but thanks for
coming with us as we explore the
character i'd of course love to hear
your thoughts so make sure you comment
below and let me know we are in a
competition right now i'm giving away
three copies of the june box set on the
28th of feb and all you have to do to be
on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the
character we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so that's you then message me
on twitter at heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of episode 6
which will be linked on screen right now
it's loads of easter eggs in it lots and
lots of cameos and we talk about them
all in this spoiler-filled review
hopefully i see over there and without
the way thanks for sticking through the
video i've been paul i'll see you on the
next one take care peace